[Music]
hello everyone
my life I'm live you can hear me
excellent welcome to our talk my name is
Michael Windsor I am a product manager
at Google I've been here for about three
years since I got here my focus has been
around G suite developer platform and
tools then leading the team towards
getting this really happy to be here and
I'm here with me as gave up you have our
email addresses they're just you know my
email address is spelled GE VA at Google
commerce really well it's good hi I'm
Gavin I'm product manager for AppMakr
I've been at Google for five years now
and I've worked on Google Maps recently
I'm from Israel and did a few startups
and work and VC's before I joined Google
and anyone who's in the room with us
today we assume that you're either an IT
developer or business analyst working a
line of business or you may be a partner
supporting companies and their business
processes they're probably some studios
and CIOs csos here we believe all of you
have business workflow challenges and
your companies and you're looking for
quick and efficient ways to deal with
them so we're here today to talk to you
about at maker this is a our solution
for internal business apps which you can
develop using low code and the key
benefits of this product are that it's
fast you can do your data binding and UI
design very quickly it's integrated so
that you can like pretty much have any
data source with your app and use any
Google service with it and it's
compliant so it's based on Google Drive
in G suite and that means that your
domain security rules apply and the data
doesn't leave your domain so I want to
start by talking a little about how we
came to this place how we came to
develop app maker and it starts really
with you the customers
when we started having conversation when
I first started Google talking to
customers about what they were trying to
do as they move towards Google they had
all these different problems that they
had previously solved in various ways
some good some bad and they wanted a way
to build these solutions running on top
of G Suites and these are problems that
are not well met by the major SAS
products so if you think about whether
it's G suite or sales force or NetSuite
or Marketo all these different things
right these are great things they solve
things very well but they tend to sort
of normalize and commoditize the problem
domain that you're working in and you
have less flexibility and so if you
think about the main style as a software
you have your line of business software
that's how we make the doughnuts
operational software which is how we pay
for the doughnuts or get them paid and
then productivity the gaps in between
those spaces are where businesses try to
automate try to connect things and make
it work well whether it's order
fulfillment or event planning whether
it's you know approvals for various
internal business work processes or
scheduling you know like planning
helpers where I need to have a queue
people can come in in the book office
hours these are things that today are
solved by horribly manual processes
involving lots of emails documents we
all seen the spreadsheets from Hell
right every business has somebody who's
basically unfired because they want
they've managed that spreadsheets is
used for some incredibly important crazy
process and everyone here is like
juggling I got you I know that guy and
you know when we see people trying to
solve this sometimes they go off and
they use various sound solutions out
there they self-serve and that creates
admin headaches they've got new silos of
data new clouds of compliance so admins
are very worried about all these
unauthorized solutions coming in there
so this is the context in which we came
and we always start solving those
problems I want to help set the picture
here was one example a few years ago at
Google our recruiters from the HR
department reached out to the IT
department we call this core bench and
they were facing a problem of really
wildly increasing volume of candidates
we were starting to see thousands of
candidates at Google every month each
one of those was interviewed by at least
one interviewer so we were getting a lot
of
textual feedbacks being piled up and it
was taking a long time and it was really
difficult to assess these feedbacks so
we were looking into some kind of
manageable solution that would also let
the recruiters calibrate the different
candidates across different skill sets
and be able to get back to the
candidates in a timely manner
so we looked into how we can build an
app that will do this quickly and
efficiently in addition to this ask from
the HR department there were different
areas different parts of Google that had
their own requests and special processes
that they wanted to tackle in a good way
so they were reaching out to the IT
department continuously with more and
more at building requests and the IT
department was also looking to automate
their own internal processes as I
believe many of you look to automate
processes like dashboards to track a lot
of projects that are ongoing so the IT
department started building business
apps to deal with their own workflow we
realized that we need a good solution
for low codes business app development
at Google so that we could actually make
our software engineers very efficient
doing these custom apps and spending the
majority of their time developing the
hard technical problems that we have and
also at the same time to empower a lot
of other different people in the company
that have some level of coding affinity
or you know like and to actually go
ahead and develop business apps on their
own or getting very little assistance so
this was really taking off very well and
we were starting to see a lot of
internal apps getting being built and
there were lots of areas that were
getting addressed by app maker as you
can see in the last few years we've got
to almost 400 apps and they have
currently hundreds and some of them even
thousands of Googlers using them
sometimes daily a lot of the people in
by the company are not even always aware
that they're actually using an app that
was built with AppMakr which is a great
success and the majority of these apps
was built by non software engineers or
with little software engineering help
and people outside of the core bench so
core bench was not tasked with taking
these things on other teams said we're
going to build this in corporations
that's okay by us a huge win and so the
major point that we want you to take
away here is that we were seeing a very
impressive transition and lowering of
the bar for building custom business
apps by moving the development of these
apps from software engineers in the IT
department solely to also seeing them
you know being built by a lot of other
different people outside of IT so let's
talk a little bit about why this is such
a point of pain all right why is it hard
to build these apps wire is IT not
prioritizing these applications and how
can we do this better so really when I
talked about how you know it's line of
business operational and productivity
well if you're a business planner when
you think about your IT spend and how
you're going to prioritize your
resources it's on the things that
absolutely matter to the business line
the business first operations second and
productivity and everything else on the
gaps will become second if it's a way
for humans to solve a problem you're
going to prioritize expensive software
development elsewhere and that is
aggravated or exacerbated by the fact
that the stakeholders are coming to you
with problems that they understand from
their perspective but they're not
software developers and not product
managers so their ability to articulate
a plan about what we should build is
just not their problem to me it's not
what they do
they are sales specialists they are HR
specialists they're all these other
things there are not product managers so
everybody in IT knows when somebody from
accounting comes to me it says I've got
this really important thing I need you
to build they have no idea what they're
talking about and you dread that you're
trying to build it right that's a big
problem
and then it's just a basic fact of
building an application is not a trivial
exercise we know how to do it there's a
well defined pattern we use different
frameworks different app systems you
know hosting environments and all these
things but there's a lot of work to
stand that up and then of course keeping
it up maintaining the code and
operationalizing and keeping it
going basis is non-trivial so these are
all things that get in the way of trying
to do that and then finally you've got
your policy and admin people telling you
apps have to conform to certain basic
thing we don't want rogue apps rogue IT
rogue data everywhere so this is just a
big problem we really need to take on
and solve in terms of how we build these
apps so we're really excited about being
to bring app maker into this space
because that maker is part of G suite it
means everybody Jesus we every G Street
for business customer has access to app
maker these applications run on and this
is a critical requirement of customs are
very clear they're run on G suite
infrastructure so they leverage all the
security all the compliance all the
scalability all the operational support
SRE
as we call it site reliability all that
is built in you have as many
applications you want the applications
are the pricing of the application is
tied into the GC for business thing it's
paid for right so it scales to the size
of your organization but you can have as
many applications as you want you can
have as many databases as you want right
it just you don't have to worry about
that problem so again from an admin and
compliance and policy one of you the
cost is built-in to your GC for business
license scales to organization and the
whole goal is to extend to enhance your
productivity suite
whether it's G suite apps or third-party
apps that are part of your your
portfolio to integrate them and to
create a more solution oriented space
for your your business users this is
Mike's life yeah so now well we're going
to invite Chris to show you hands-on how
to build an app maker app right here now
hey guys so let me just go ahead and
switch over to my screen
good see it so once they switch over to
them okay great so hello how you guys
doing my name is chris or christian
shulk so i've actually been working with
that maker for a number of years
probably more years than I care to admit
and so a lot of apps that Gabe was
referring to actually was helping you
know build out a lot of those solutions
internally Google so I'm happy to at
least give you a hopefully a quick demo
of what a picker looks like so let me
just switch over into how to build an
application so what I'm going to do is
just create an application based off of
a spreadsheet and it's just a matter of
minutes so in this case what we're
looking at is the app maker environment
and I'm going to create a new data model
so also I should point out this is based
off of a template so if you ever want to
get started with that maker you actually
have like a whole series of different
template applications some of them are
quite sophisticated but in this case I
just used like a simple starter app
which gives us like the menu header and
so forth so that's what we're looking at
right here so let's create a back-end
data model so the size of this is like
the backend database for our application
it's going to utilize Google Drive table
which is a new database that you get for
free whenever you build an app maker and
I'm going to create a model that's going
to in this case it's like a series of
stores like a global registry of stores
that we need to set up a way to do
on-site inspections and so in this case
I'm going to first click on import the
fields but I can go ahead and base the
app maker data model off of this
spreadsheet so I happen to have my
spreadsheet accessible as a Google Drive
picker window and I once I select it it
has actually scan a little bit of the
data so I can visually confirm that yep
that's the data that I want to base my
new model off of it will then go through
it and essentially guess at what are the
data types with my fields and I'll click
create and now we have a new data model
now if I wanted to I could go in and
further customize the fields like adding
validation and such and while I'm at it
I'm going to go ahead and actually
import the data as well so let's just go
ahead and select the store and I since I
have a global store sheet handy it'll
keep that ready to go and that will
start the connection now to the actual
spreadsheet and start pulling that data
over and I can even return back to the
main page
well that import is done other rego is
already finished now I can switch over
and start building the UI now the first
thing that you typically want to do is
set up like a default data source for
your UI so in this case I'm just going
to point it to the stores directly and
so that makes data binding a lot easier
so I can start to drag and drop widgets
which in this case I just drag a form
and so the idea being that I can build
forms tables or really any UI construct
very easily by dragging and dropping the
widgets in this case it's like the
composite widget is going to build me an
entire insert form and so for this one I
want to keep it simple I just want a
couple of fields I want the location and
I want the inspection date and we'll
leave it as that I'll click finish so
there we go we got a four mega generated
for me if I want to customize this
further I could pick out the fields or
whatever and now I'm going to drag and
drop a table and the table is going to
essentially get a rate through all the
records and for this one I'm just going
to select location I'll add rating so
like when you do a site inspection you
can put that data in there and of course
the date and for this one I'm going to
have editable fields click Next and
finish that one off so now we have a
design time view of our table and we
just kind of size it a bit so as you can
see with the at maker visual you know
environment quite easy to customize the
UI as needed and I'm going to add
another widget so I just do like a quick
search on the palette and we happen to
have a Google Maps widget as we drop
that on to the page in this case I'm
just going to kind of resize it a bit so
that it will stretch over to the size of
the top two forms and doesn't where it
gets fun because I can data bind the
widget over here on the property editor
and I pop it open into binding mode and
I just set the location so now whenever
I'm pointing to a record it will then
show that now there's another
customization I'm going to do right now
I just have a text field that's got
generated for me
but I'm going to spice it up a bit with
a star rating widget so I drag and drop
the e star
would you stick it right next to the
rating and we can blow away their rating
and then you can guess what my next step
is right I need to set the value to a
data valid value coming from my back-end
database and set it to rating and so
that's basically it for now I'm going to
go ahead and click preview so new cent
what it's doing is taking what I've done
what I've designed visually compiling
that into Apps Script and sent over to
the Apps Script runtime so now we are
looking at this data right here where I
can you know click through and maybe
sort the data or even directly change
some of the data and of course if I
wanted to add some data here like maybe
our Paris locations loops and maybe
select a particular date I love the
accessibility features I can do all that
very easily and so now I have a new
record so we have a store in Paris that
we go and inspect all right so let's go
back and add a little bit more
functionality to the application so in
that case I'm going to add a little bit
of scripting and the idea being that
whenever I insert a new record I might
want to end an email to the person
that's actually you know inserting or
repressing in these store inspections
and so how can I do that well I happen
to have a little bit of code here which
if you go through it a little bit more
closely but basically this is a bit of
code that's just using Apps Script
directly to then send an email to the
person who's doing that so now all I
have to do is create a new script so we
have a nice script generation wizard and
it will even generate some sample code
as well and so this script is going to
be running on the server so it's running
Apps Script so I click create and
there's a little bit of example code
that you can learn from in this case I
just paste that new function that I
created this one is called this is a
function called notify and I want this
to be called whenever I create a new
record in my database so I can go back
to my data model click on event and then
on the on create event I could just call
the function directly and here I can
specify the actual record
of which contains the location as well
as the inspection date those are just
eight objects so that's going to fire
off that whenever I created code a new
record so let's go ahead you again also
I should check my email here so there's
no emails in the queue for now don't
want to turn off my Wi-Fi all right so
let's create a new inspection
Michael gather any location we're going
to Helsinki Helsinki okay yep Chelsea
heat is second I hear it's really nice
right now tell stinky and what date do
we want sometimes I'd like to go there
more dark times of winter how's June
sound okay yeah all right there we go so
we're all set now let's go check our
email and see if we got eight matches Oh
surprise surprise I have an inspection
alert so greetings your store at the
Helsinki location will be inspected blah
blah so that's basically it hopefully
give you an idea of how you can work
with that maker starting with a
spreadsheet so I can drop some widget
put a little bit of coding in there
and we're just literally scratching the
surface so if you have a chance please
come to our demo ground up on the third
floor about CEO need will show you a
whole bunch more stuff as well so I want
to take them up
just I mean I wasn't timing and I really
should like that was five maybe eight
minutes to build an app now that's not
an app that you know is everything
everybody could constantly imagine but
it's an app that it can be used right
away and it's like literally
personification of agile where this is
what you asked me for show me what you
need next show me what you used
right you can put an analytics into your
app you can start gathering data you
start knowing what your customers need
and the investment time there was
trivial right and you can easily imagine
that person who knows nothing about
product development sing down thanks to
someone like Chris and saying I need
something to do this and it starts with
a spreadsheet and turns into a useable
application where now it's managed
auditable trackable everything and you
can start integrating other workflows
and then all the things that you want to
start having happening are no longer
like oh god I'm back in that spreadsheet
from Hell trying to write a macro so
these are some other other customers
that we've worked with early on in the
stage of the building out at Maker
they've been our partners for a long
time and helping us flesh out the
product build real-life use cases I just
want to call them out in particular the
state of Colorado sent me know and the
state of Wyoming is Flint here Flint are
you here I can't see him it's like
you're all dark bodies in a gray
background right now but Flint is
actually this was the CIO of the state
of Wyoming they got in and got in really
early and did some great things and he's
actually loved it so much he now works
at Google so that worked out really well
for us no it doesn't work out if you all
build app maker applications I can't
hire every single one of it it's not I'm
not allowed to do that but so I want to
talk a little bit about one of our other
customers who have also been a
tremendous partner with us
they got involves relatively early as
well al kado is an online retailer in
the UK they have a lot of employees they
have a lot of you know technology
investment it's a big engineering
department there but like I said those
engineers are very focused on their core
line of business requirements as the
business is growing they're solving
business problems but they have a lot of
people doing things including training
conferences going to conferences like
this taking on training activities and
so forth and this was literally just a
like entire mess of emails manual
processes multiple spreadsheets
I'm sure paper was involved at some
point it was an incredibly taxing
process it was inefficient nobody knew
what was going on
if you wanted to find out what
conferences have been approved to go to
or standard process there was no way to
know you just had to know the right
person and no management around budget
or approvals is just like you know
Fred's that it was okay I'm going they
felt that app maker was a perfect
opportunity to kind of automate that
process for them and so they were able
to sit down and start building out an
application in very little time and so
they actually now have a deployed to
production application being used by
hundreds of employees to go to
conferences to manage the process to
workflow around it to set up training
now this is where things get really good
so Chris blows that application in about
five minutes they built their training
management tool and conference
attendance attendance management tool in
30 hours not 30 calendar hours thirty
engineering hours is spread out of a
course in about a few weeks in 30 hours
they built and deployed that application
now is that application perfect I don't
know I've never used it I'm sure it's
amazing but thirty hours is really
amazing how quickly you can get to
something being used that's a big deal
so you've heard I forgot to sorry I
forgot to my post quote Paul as the CTO
IG got to meet him last night as Paul
here any chance another dark grey cloud
of people they get it right Paul
understood that they could go and take
on problems they could never have taken
on before and I want to I have said this
several times I want to say it again app
maker is not about building the apps
that you're building today where you
have a stack where you have a production
environment where you're focused on line
of business operations it's about taking
on all those apps that you desperately
want to have in your business but simply
could never bother to take on all right
because the cost was too high the
viability was not obvious or clear these
are tremendous opportunities for your
business and you have a huge pent-up
need that you may not even be talking
about and this is what that makers about
and they got it they were all over that
start gala you've heard about a few
customer stories seeing how to build an
app very quickly I want to tell you
where we are today with other hundreds
of customers that we have so we started
rolling this out externally about a year
ago and we had over thirty large
customers that we were helping build
their first apps and iterating with them
and seeing a lot of the problems that
our product had and
fixed all those before we launched last
November through our early adopter
program this program is available to
every G Suite business customer with an
application and we now have hundreds of
customers that are building hundreds of
applications using the product the
general ability launch is planned for
later this year and by that time we'll
have passed the audit process that all
Google new products go so we will be
compliant with international standards
and we are also working on great
features to add to the product before we
launch it as an automatic service in G
suite like part of all the other core
services that we have in v3 today and if
you're wondering how you can actually
get into the early adopter program this
is very simple we have a website where
you can enter your details preferably
get your admin to do it because this is
the person we are looking to approve
this application so if somebody else in
the company does that we'll get back to
you and ask for the admin to do it
g3 google.com /f maker and that starts
the process rolling all right so I'm
going to talk a little bit about I think
we told you why we got here the
customers wanted our internal problems
Chris gave a great demo so set you up
for how you're going to follow up what I
want to know is a little bit of a dive
in terms of like why these things are
important and sort of you know since you
just a first pass that the different
features and capabilities that are built
into a maker and why they're interesting
so as you saw from Chris's demo it's a
visual tool right there on the screen
cloud-based fire up any editor any
browser anywhere you want and you're up
and running and getting things done drag
and drop for you I you know again you
know there are snap tools there are
guides to observer it's layout things
that built in there those a lot of use
to customize the user experience and
again you want these applications to
look nice they don't experience nirvana
but you want it to look nice material
design is built-in if you want to have
different themes and looks you can do
that as well and everything is HTML
Javascript CSS standards
is a very standards based product so if
you want to go and beyond what we've
done you want to customize the
experience the first level in just
within our editor all the terms and
concepts will be familiar to you but you
can then dive in deeper and start
customizing the HTML the CSS directly
and even writing client-side code in
JavaScript to automate and build out a
richer front-end that goes beyond what
we build into our widgets and that's
really powerful and we've seen some
amazing applications one of the internal
applications we have takes ammount of d3
the data visualization tool does just
amazing things all data bound to the
AppMakr data behind the scenes so
standards-based sort of runtime and
application frameworks the data modeling
another big thing right one of the big
challenges for the data is just general
challenge standing up data keeping at
the bribe available managing a life
cycle of data managing the access the
data are all challenges that people have
to deal with we make that very easy it's
all point-and-click and you saw how
Chris did he started from a spreadsheet
right and you know that most of your
apps are going to start from that
spreadsheet from hell boom the data is
there and then yeah you can go off and
you can do full relational data modeling
you can have all kinds of events and
triggers hanging off the data and you
can build custom data models so you can
write JavaScript code to create your own
custom data model for an arbitrary data
source that you want and we're going to
keep extending that and gave us a hint
of that around connectivity to other
data sources because we know all right
it's all very well to talk about your
data in terms of this application you
want integrate this across the space to
the rest of your applications part of
your business um we have a lot of you
know Chris again shows you that sort of
page full of samples I want to talk
about that for a second because it's not
just sample code we actually have a
growing library of what I'm calling
ready to use applications so these are
applications where we didn't just build
something that looks nice or it's a
sample it shows you how to use this
feature of that feature this is a
turnkey application you get it a source
code you de put you know provision it
and deploy it using app maker and use it
as is and the application itself has an
admin model where you can go on and then
the admin can set it up and customize
the experience of the application to put
your your business name and your icons
and those logos you'd like and customize
various preferences for the application
it's a SAS product but you run and
operate on top of our infrastructure and
we have a growing number of applications
available today and we're going to keep
adding to them so one of them today we
have is
essentially a clone of our own internal
people directory this is key zones of
the directory services features of G
suite and provides a nice directory
service view into the thing and then we
have other apps as well workflow and so
forth and this is a key part of our
business strategy we're going to keep
building out these apps I feel like I'm
at the Academy Awards now where I'm
getting the music telling me to go to
the next slide and the timing like that
so you've just totally throw me off it's
perfect there you go so it's not just
about you know building an app that
lives in its own silo it is about
integration to other services about
connecting to your various parts of your
business so first of all you know within
Apps Script everybody's used app script
knows you have great access to G suite
API is but you also have great access to
other Google cloud platform API s and
that list will just keep getting longer
and longer and longer as we build those
integrations in we're also building in
features in the future towards other
services to make it easy to take the
same sort of off magic anybody here ever
had to write a wall code on purpose all
right
anybody want to do it again right right
so we built the OAuth code into you we
do the office management for you for all
the Google services and G suite services
what we're going to do is going to go
past that and start working in
third-party service as well to get you
having that ease of use to talk to all
indicated services big deal this is just
the icon soup page or the NASCAR page if
you will of various sort of services ago
that does anybody know what the one in
the middle is must be an ads with my bad
isn't anybody there's an ad thing
Adsense that's me I knew it's something
really vital and important to our
business all right we'll keep going here
so just a quick over a few year of the
overall architecture of how things are
put together this is obviously a
beautifully abstract architecture that
bears no resemblance to how things are
built and how the sausage is made but
it's actually important to understand
how we think about the problem and how
deployments come together so at the top
of this of course is the app maker
editor that's the experience that you
saw Chris demoing it is the IDE
you can edit source code you can build
out you guys going to get these slides
and the video so you get better visuals
of these in your pictures I'm guessing
but you know feel free and that
application maintains and manages the
source code of the application manages
revisions of the application manages
access and collaboration is fully closed
with real-time collaborators you can
have most people work in that editor
environment that application that when
Chris hits preview or publish to go off
and deploy the application is generating
an Apps Script project and that Apps
Script project is pushed on to the Apps
Script execution environment and now
runs using Apps Script now this is not
the same Apps Script that you have might
have become familiar with it is a
massively enhanced version of Apps
Script and that's now available to all G
Suites for business customers with
increased capacity better performance
increased connectivity various services
more API quota and throughput so we're
really beefing up the run time to make
app maker fly as I've mentioned before
we've also extended what we're doing
within Apps Script to make various
things possible so obviously all the
Google services those are familiar like
that drive table this is the built-in
storage model module for AppMakr it
stores data in its own private data
store it's highly performant it's not
meant to scale to giant data sets so
please don't think this is a cheap way
to get bigquery going on your little
world and we'll talk about bigquery in a
second but it is exactly what you need
for 90% of your applications and when
you feel like your needs have changed or
you want to interrupt with other systems
data as well right you can switch to
using cloud sequel and then you'll also
be able to switch to Postgres or my
sequel and then other data sources as
well so that's a list of expanding data
connectors that were going to build out
and then those same data connector
things will also work to talking to SAS
services that are not strictly speaking
a database but maybe like Salesforce or
something like that where you want to
get to enterprise data and build a data
binding into your application before you
know doing something else and I already
forgot was going to do so another brief
call out the state of Wyoming it because
it really illustrates how things came
together so the state of Wyoming has a
great IT department they've been
building out things on gee suite for a
while they've done Apps Script and
various things they have a team that is
responsible for essentially security of
their environment the software
environment and they have a set of tools
that they use to to track and detect you
know phishing attacks and various things
they leverage G Suites both in services
but they have a bunch of other products
as well and they wanted to kind of pull
together a 360 dashboard of all the
things that could happen this has been a
long-standing wish of theirs but they
could never really pull it together
again with AppMakr they sat down and
said we can do this and I want talk
about this picture here because
this is quite literally the guy with the
hat he's the engineer right and the
other people there are the people who
are sitting there thinking about the
business problem they are the
stakeholders here they are not engineers
and are software developers and this
picture is obviously a little bit staged
but it is actually how things happen
they sat down and said what we want is
this information here we want to track
these things here we're gonna pull these
things together there and the engineer
was able to do this on the fly and in a
matter of days they had something
working in a matter of weeks they had
something deployed and they are now
actively tracking and building out this
application as a way to track their
security events across the organization
how to respond how to work flow around
them so when something happens it's not
just hey something seems bad there's a
whole process that kicks off around that
so really great story for how you can
build out applications and compress that
cycle where the stakeholders the
engineering get to market get to usage
happens much faster so you learn what
you need to know faster and you spend
less risk less time and less effort
getting there we want all of you to be
able to focus on your business needs and
be able to expect what kind of problems
you need to solve and we want to help
you identify what are the best
candidates in your companies to actually
will that make your apps around so we
want to share some of the areas where
we've seen a lot of hairiness and
business workflows that require easy you
know better use and more productive
workflows so the first one which we've
already mentioned here several times is
sheet sheets especially very large ones
especially the ones that have more than
a handful of people updating them on the
regular basis usually hide some kind of
process that's being done internally and
hasn't been fleshed out you know to the
extreme and so a lot of times their
error is happening several times people
are updating the wrong cells they're
extracting you know taking decisions
based on information that's maybe not
accurate and in general there is you
know it's not a very good experience to
start diving into a sheet and look for
the information that especially critical
to you so this is an area where
taking app maker specking your UI
binding it to this data source to the
sheet and building the process in this
UI could really change things for the
better
another area that we've seen is around
administrative tasks and that relates to
bulk and recurring operations with other
GC Kotzur core services especially
calendar and Gmail if we look for
example at the store inspection
application that we saw this is
something that without the application
requires scheduling tens of events
across the year attaching documents
those calendar invites
there must be errors if you want to
update those you again have to find the
right calendar entry and update that one
same way if you're sending updates or
reports or if you're requesting
information from customers vendors
partners you're generating the same kind
of Gmail blasts every week or 10 days or
months and this is another area where
you could automate and have a much more
fluid experience with AppMakr the third
area that we have seen where people
could benefit from building an app is
where you use bigquery a loss where
you're calling API you're already using
scripting in extensive ways so that
means that you've probably already
tackled some complex workflows but in
order to maintain those workflows change
them make a UI nicer it would be much
better to use app maker to tackle those
and I want to talk a little bit about
bigquery for seconds that was the thing
I forgot to talk about we've got you
seen an increasingly common pattern you
know bigquery is not free and people
want to have various UI into bigquery
data and what people are starting to
build is that make your applications
that are essentially this front-end to
bigquery experience where it helps the
user construct the query figure out what
they trying to do connect the various
pieces they want runs the bigquery and
then cache as the results in a local
data store which then can be used for
multiple traversals and exploring and
exports and whatever so you essentially
uses a cache for the output of a
bigquery response you might choose not
to rerun the query over and over again
because he's just sitting there poking
around the data it's been tremendously
effective to
a pattern to build on we're going to
start building out samples in the same
way Thanks so this is a great point in
time to hear from two people that we
have in the audience with us today about
their experience and how they tackle
problems that they face their company's
first I'd like to call us
Mario Zuniga from San Nina so everyone
can hear me okay so I've been in Femina
for ten years living enterprise
application development teams and lately
in the last three years I'm responsible
for the digital workplace team that
that's responsible for all the
cooperation platforms and Google is one
of our main pieces in our portfolio so
when we heard about app maker and early
last year we we got very interested
because it fits very well our cloud
centric strategy we want to Google about
cloud first whenever we are looking for
applications and the fact that the
application is in the cloud and is
following the same kind of structure and
using a single technology it's a great
thing for us so as you guys mentioned
there's there always the need for local
applications for specific use cases we
as an enterprise team cannot resolve all
the business problems because we have
too much and the big thing is is timing
so instead of weeks we can develop up
our applications in in hours
also the fact that we have all the
applications in a central place we also
reduce the rework so if the plant in
Brazil has developed the application to
resolve the business problem a and there
is a plant in Australia that is looking
for the same kind of problem resolution
they can reuse that same application and
avoid rework so for us going forward we
want to invest
more in a in a maker development the use
case that we see today are basically
four simple workflows and and paper
reduction as an attraction company we
have lots of inspections and checklists
and many things that ad maker is just a
agree sheet awesome thank you very much
you next is James Ferreira from ignites
energy everyone so ignites energy is a
business that we were a software
development company on Apps Script
written to O'Reilly books on Apps Script
so when we heard about app maker we were
super excited that it was a new platform
built on top of Apps Script and so we
provided a product that I want to
announce today is called app maker
University and what we're doing is
providing training for app maker and
online training on online videos and
also in person and boot camps and things
like that and I want to a mission a
couple of the clients that we're working
with that we're helping train them some
of you are here in the audience so just
scream out we go there we go alright
they're awesome
so one of the companies were working
with is Cora and they had a course of
spreadsheet based application that was
doing scheduling and things like that
and it just isn't scalable it's really
hard to manage there are constantly
duplicating it and having to rebuild it
and so we suggested well why don't we
try app maker so we're moving that
project over to app maker we're also
working with a company called MSA there
are a large construction company and
they have built their entire business
process in spreadsheets and I actually
helped them do some of that by writing
app scripts to make those spreadsheets
connect to things and services and work
well and when we saw that maker were
like wow you could rebuild your whole
entire business process in app maker and
so that's exactly what they're doing
they're really excited to be doing that
so lots of great stuff going on a little
bit about app maker University in terms
of what the goal is yeah so the goals
apnic or university is you know we
realized that you know the it's a
brand-new product there's really no
books written on it or anything else
like that there's not a lot of areas to
find out how you can start get started
so we've got a lot of getting started
videos a lot of extra money
about how you use the different widgets
what they actually do how you set them
up how you go about creating apps and
we're providing a bootcamp as well so
that you can go from no knowledge at all
to completed applications and have a
really high level ability to be able to
create those for your businesses so we
found during our trusted tester program
that we had people come in and do boot
camps with authentic James Bay's could
took all their ideas and stole them and
turn it into a product I applaud you for
it sir it's so great like that ya know
it's excited if friends it's exactly we
want is you know it there's only so many
of us who can talk to so many of you
extending the reach is really critical I
think that if your company isn't
starting to engage and thinking about
building it up maker dive in by all
means but accelerate the process by
bringing in people who've been doing
this for a while they know the pitfalls
it'll be a ways to go do as best
practices it's a great story so I'm
actually really glad you're starting as
a key part of our long-term strategy so
thank you thank you thank you and thank
you as we head towards the end of our
talk we want to mention what's next for
the product and what's next for you in
the audience and your companies so
you've seen a lot of functionality that
we presented here today and we want to
tell you what are the three main themes
that we are focusing on before general
availability later this year one area
where we see a lot of demand is to
connect app maker the platform to a lot
of data sources that you already have in
your companies and you would benefit
from building business apps around those
so we'll look into I mean we're actually
already developing some ways to connect
these external third-party data sources
to our platform and we believe that this
would really ease the migration of many
non G Suite environments to G suite the
second theme space that we are working
on is to make the product even faster
and easier so we are going to provide
more templates and ready to use apps
we're also looking to have modules that
are part of apps that you could use and
actually build your own apps in a faster
and easier way so you can mix and match
functionalities that are common to
several apps
and that would make everything even
easier more useful and faster 13 is to
create an echo system so we heard from
Mario for example that in large
companies different departments
different plans tend to have similar
needs and they may you know grassroots
develop the same kind of apps multiple
times so if we have a good way to engage
like a broad audience inside the company
with what's being developed by other
people that could be very useful and we
are looking at the best way to let you
share your applications with others
inside the company and also with the
broader at maker community so any
company that is using app maker could
benefit from an asset was willed by
another company so if you're willing to
share your code and help others that
will be great we've seen a lot of
interest in like not the actual app
itself but various components and pieces
so the packaging solutions that will
make up app maker are going to be part
of that story really interested in
moving that direction and what's next
for all of you like as you head out of
this room in a few minutes so you can
learn more about the product by looking
at our tutorials on the Google developer
site if you're already in our early
adopter program or you would like to see
some of the questions and issues that
our users already bringing you can join
the app maker users group and see what's
being posted and discussed over there
there are also code labs that you can
access through the group and actually
you know take some learning exercises
for yourself and see how that goes and
very relevant we have a showcase at
Moscone West and level 3 so we really
like to see all of you and as you try
hands-on you know playing with the
product yourself right now and also
meeting a lot of our engineering team
that's on site and can you know get into
much deeper details with any one of you
so we'll be there until the end of the
conference on Friday afternoon and
remember
anyone who wants to apply and register
and be part of our early adopter program
it's very easy you either you know need
to be I mean you're either a DC business
customer already or if you're
considering - that's a good decision to
make and then you can apply and get into
the program Michael all right so we've
covered a lot of material going to bring
it together we really hope you've
enjoyed this talk simple call to action
go to the showcase today try AppMakr
join the AP start building great
business apps low code faster
development cycles internal applications
scale with the size of your organization
I want to thank in particular the app
maker engineering team they have been
working on this literally for years
there's been a tremendous project and
we're really excited to bring this to
market I want to thank our partners as
well both those those who've been up
here today but also people who've been
with us for a long time the trusted
tester that gave on Chris is doing great
precision presentation and thank you to
you for coming today we've really
enjoyed this talk hope you did as well
thank you
[Music]
you
[Music]